hi my name is Bill Brenly with net hope
and one of the most interesting things
I've heard it wet while I've been here
is around youth and the opportunity to
reach them in emerging markets and in
the developing world in particular
through serious gaming all of this could
apply to the developed world as well and
that is that you can use games such as
we PEPFAR and the israeli-palestinian
conflict ators have been developed and
are being now developed in Jordan to
reach young people with something that
engages them in terms of their
intellects but also their emotions but
around serious topics such as conflict
resolution such as learning about
hiv/aids in the case of PEPFAR and
looking at ways to understand norms and
values in a more powerful way that they
can consume through the use of a very
interesting game so that's been one of
the more interesting things that really
pertains to the whole area of reaching
youth but also the next generation and
using all the tools that are available
to us to them
you